here's the latest from Lamborghini the
new Heric on LP 582 the car looks
basically the same as the standard
all-wheel drive version but it's brand
new two wheel drive configuration gives
drivers the ability to do the power
slides and drifting that they can't do
on the 240 thousand dollar Heric on this
is something super emotional for those
who truly love Lamborghini according to
company has stephan winkelmann the main
difference is you have the opportunity
to three when everyone dies so it's for
Voight Spears people but also for
younger people meanwhile this car is
just a little lighter and stiffer than
the regular Heric on and it's a little
slower to with the same be 10 5.2 liter
engine with 580 horsepower but a 60 mile
per hour sprint time of 3.4 seconds
rather than 3.2 aesthetically the
changes are just as subtle the front has
been tightened to look a little more
aggressive the air intakes have been
widened the tires inflated but Lambo
says everything will also be cheaper
expect to see this car come in right
around two hundred thousand dollars call
it the more accessible Lamborghini
Huracan if you can imagine that it'll go
on sale in the middle of next year